[Applaudissements]
bonsoir chantes tu tantôt
cette question à chaque fois que je vois
mon grand-père ou gelée au téléphone il
appose ça lui fait plaisir de connaître
l'itinéraire de ma tournée je pense à
elle rassure aussi un peu dit bon ça va
il galère pas trop et la can des dates
et il ya trois ans je me souviens je
suis allé prendre le goûter chez lui et
il m'a posé cette question chantes tu
t'entends je lui ai donné la liste des
concerts des semaines à venir et en même
temps j'ai senti dans cette question
comme un point d'interrogation un peu
plus profond un peu plus épineux que
justesse que tu as des concerts comme
s'il me demande est ce que tu as envie
de faire ça de ta vie en fait est ce que
tu as envie un moment d'y plonger corps
et âme à ce moment là j'étais en master
1 de médias et communication au celsa
quelle école de communication et de
journalisme de la sorbonne et avant de
partir en stage il fallait qu'on rendait
en mémoire et comme la musique occuper
pas mal de temps déjà dans ma vie
j'avais des concerts beaucoup de
premières parties j'allais rentrer dans
la phase d'enregistrement mon premier
album
donc j'ai négocié avec la direction un
passe droit et pour avoir un sujet de
mémoire adapté dont j'ai moi même choisi
l'énoncé est l'intitulé était enjeux et
perspectives de la médiatisation de
carrière d'un jeune artiste musical en
développement tim cup juste un peu
schizophrène et je me retrouve avec ce
sujet de mémoire et c'est marrant parce
qu'on écoles on nous parlait tout le
temps de notion de neutralité
axiologique de réflexivité autant vous
dire que l'on n'y était pas du tout et
donc quand mon grand père me pose cette
question bat ça me travaille je rentre
chez moi le soir est impossible de
trouver le sommeil ça mouline et sous
les coups des quatre heures du matin je
me lève et sous l'impulsion seront mon
ordi
et je tape si cette page au traitement
de texte et ses pages là vont finir sous
la forme d'une lettre à direction de la
directrice de master et en fait je lui
dis que je quitte l'école que j'arrête
les études et je fais cette lettre par
une phrase pleine de bons sentiments mes
très sincères il est temps pour moi
d'être artiste il est temps pour moi
d'être heureux alors pour être honnête
en vrai un mémoire à rendre un an et
demi d'études dans une vie c'est pas non
plus la mer à boire
mais ça me paraissait tellement longs et
surtout tellement décalé de ce que
j'avais envie de faire
donc si j'ai pris le pari d'envoyer
cette lettre est peut-être de mettre à
dos mon entourage mes parents
occasionnellement la direction mon label
qui s'était mis aussi un peu en garant
de confiance auprès de mes parents je
n'y étais pas il va finir ses études
tu parles et bah si j'ai fait ce pari là
c'est parce que j'étais fort d'une
intuition elle même née d'une succession
de doutes qui s'étaient accumulés dans
ma vie les années précédentes comme les
pierres d'un chemin qui maintenant était
enfin de baliser la première fois que
j'ai été confronté aux doutes sérieux
doutes existentiels parce que liée à la
mort à la disparition et et au deuil
d'un être cher ça a été ma cousine et ma
grand-mère et ce doute là il m'a
interrogé sur mon rapport à la vigne le
sens que je lui donnais sur ma condition
d'être de passage et sur la transmission
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on laisse de nous
qu'est ce que laisse ces gens
une fois parti comme mémoire comme
souvenir comme empreinte comme le sont
le deuxième doute il est lié aux savoirs
et ça c'est mes études qu'ils ont
distillé peu à peu à travers des
rencontres déjà bon la plupart du temps
quand on peut c'est ça aussi les études
c'est rencontrer des gens qui viennent
de milieux et de contextes
socioculturels différents des nôtres
ça dépend des études et pour le goût moi
ça a été le cas donc s'armer quand même
pas mal de choses en question et ensuite
ça a été des matières et des disciplines
je pense à la sociologie l'ethnologie
les sciences politiques qu'on a un peu
chamboulé pas mal de conviction que je
pouvais avoir qu'elle soit spirituel ou
politiques etc ont aussi changé cette
vision que j'avais un peu dichotomique
du monde
vrai ou faux bond mauvais juste injuste
ça me donnait plus de nuances
en fait est le troisième grand passeur
de doute ça a été les voyages
j'ai eu la chance déjà petit en famille
de voyage et mes parents ont quand même
toujours transmis ce cet esprit de
curiosité et après j'ai voyagé par les
études je suis parti en erasmus en
angleterre accroché leicester s'est pas
pardon c'est dans l'essex les sexes est
un peu la sarthe britannique non plus
j'aime beaucoup la sarthe mais et
c'était assez haut parce que j'étais
dans une coloc on était sept de pays
différents et avec des personnalités
quand même assez fort j'avais par
exemple encore localement qu'il parlait
de schopenhauer au petit déj en bouffant
du roquefort et c'était l'endroit idéal
en fait pour pour remettre en cause des
tas de clichés et préjugés qu'on avait
les uns sur les autres
et ensuite j'ai voyagé seul ou entre
amis
et là ça a été des voyages plus longs
plus loin qu'on était des vrais boussole
intérieure parce que à chaque fois la
culture la tradition l'histoire la
nourriture la façon de penser de devoir
la vie la mort la fête tout était
différent ce qui décale les perspectives
ce qui fait du bien j'ai eu la chance de
sillonner une bonne partie de l'europe
je suis allé en islande aussi au maghreb
au canada aux états unis en inde au
japon les pays vraiment vraiment sublime
et en même temps je mesure que c'est
aussi une chance pour moi le voyage
parce que c'est quand même partir avec
l'idée que je peux rentrer un moment
c'est pas uniquement fuir et j'ai aussi
pas mal vadrouillé en france surtout
métropolitaine parce que là les tournées
de concerts c'est ça aussi on sillonne
les routes un peu partout on voit des
gens différents partout et en même temps
assez semblable avec beaucoup d'à sont
blanches ne serait-ce que l'envié de
réussir sa vie
trouver un endroit dans lequel
s'épanouir s'émanciper et voyager c'est
c'est à chaque fois remettre en cause
ses habitudes ses rengaines son confort
ce sont tous ces doutes là qui sont
empilés les uns sur les autres mais
sereinement qui m'ont fait prendre
conscience en fait que j'avais le droit
et même que j'avais le devoir d'admettre
que le doute c'est une force que je ne
sais pas tout blanc là et que rien n'est
tout à fait véritable intangible
immuable je suis pas complotistes mais
mais je crois qu'il ya pas de règles en
fait douter c'est pas c'est pas remettre
en cause des convictions c'est les
épaules et sait les nuances et doute et
c'est sans doute ce écouter davantage
faire confiance à son inspiration à son
intuition à sa sensibilité
c'est pas être naïf
donc avec le recul si est ce que cette
décision que j'ai pris en envoyant cette
lettre est ce qu elle était vraiment un
contre-courant de mon point de vue non
en fait elle était tellement rationnelle
mais elle était à contre-courant de ce
qu'il était à peu près commun de faire à
ce moment là et je me suis permis de
douter de ce qui était familialement
valable de ce qui était socialement
appropriées pour faire mon choix et je
regrette vraiment pas alors j'ai eu une
discussion avec un pote le week-end
dernier qu'il disait qui croyais pas du
tout au libre arbitre
il ya sans doute du vrai là dedans je
pense que on et contextualisés
évidemment toute notre vie et ça a ainsi
dû aussi sur sur nos choix mais je crois
qu'il ya une fenêtre ouverte quand même
un champ d'action dans lequel les
individus un moment donné on deux
trajectoires et peuvent choisir aussi de
leur propre chef
j'aurais bien aimé que des amis et des
gens que j'ai rencontrés viennent aussi
vous parler de contre-courant parce que
au quotidien il avance à contre-courant
dans leurs actions dans leur combat je
pense à frédéric et pierre de wendake
une association qui vient en aide aux
femmes et aux enfants victimes de
violence conjugale je pense à guillaume
qui va en tchétchénie et qui permet à
des gens de fuir les arrestations des
persécutions trouvé asile en france je
pense à martin qui a repris la ferme de
son père pour en faire un domaine
maraîcher bio et qui se bat au quotidien
contre le lobbying et l'agrobusiness des
grandes surfaces
je pense à ces gens qui sont là aussi ce
soir qui parle de contre-courant il ya
beaucoup de gens qui avancent à contre
courant au quotidien et l'enjeu c'est
peut-être de faire c'est de ces
contre-courant justement des courants
dominants parce qu'ils sont justes et
parce qu'ils sont essentiels
leur histoire elle est pas vraiment
comparable à la mienne mais s'il fallait
tirer un trait commun
c'est peut-être ce doute cet accueil du
doute celui qu'on fait fleurir qu'on
cultive celui auquel on veille qui nous
donne de la nuance
ce doute qui fait qu'à un moment on
trouve son endroit on s'y épanouit et
dans le meilleur des cas on s'émancipe
et ça je vous le souhaite à toutes et
tous merci
[Applaudissements]